if ireland is to become a new island she
must first become european wrote the
great irish writer james joyce as
ireland's seventh presidency of the eu
council ended tishock ender kenny
thanked meps for their help in achieving
several things like agreement on the
eu's budget for the next seven years and
reform of the common agricultural policy
i believe that what we have achieved in
that regard
has bolstered the credibility of the
european union
its role
and its work
in the eyes of our people and of our
citizens
most meps felt mr kenny's government had
done as well as they could in the
economic circumstances although some are
worried about the budget deal tens of
billions of euros cut not to salaries
not to bloated expenses but instead to
funding for workers who lose their jobs
to erasmus to development programs to
heating funds and i think i mean you
know european people will unfortunately
feel the effects of this in the next
seven years
eighty percent of europeans see chemical
pollution as a threat to water quality
the water framework directive adopted in
2000 provides a list of hazardous
pollutants and sets environmental
quality standards now 12 more chemicals
are being added to the priority list
plus for the first time three
pharmaceutical products will come in for
scrutiny i think we need more data about
this issue and we need an overall
strategy but it is for sure that in the
future we have to address this problem
because there are effects proven effects
to the aquatic environment and to other
animals and of course the human kind as
well
increasing minimum standards for regular
vehicle checks are part of a strategy to
har road deaths in the eu by 2020. the
mep who wrote the report a qualified
engineer wants a regulation not a
directive to ensure even application
there will be tests too for two-wheeled
vehicles caravans and road-going
agricultural tractors the report sets
stringent technical standards in an
80-page annex
brakes steering
and also power pack that's very
interesting and and also the issues
regarding and
environmental aspects motorcycle tests
start in 2016.